yeah have you guys had any near-death
experiences before
i told the story about how i'd like got
launched with a bounce castle right
yes oh yeah that was probably one as
well yeah cause i remember i
remember telling you this uh like a few
days ago but uh i think the nearest
death experience i had was like
the most probably the most lamest story
i could tell yeah but uh it was during a
snowball fight
right so so in university uh
in england we don't get a lot of snow we
get like snow once or twice a year right
right
and so anytime it snows everyone takes
the opportunity to play around in the
snow
and in university what that means is we
just go out and have a bunch of snowball
fights right
so it was uh like one dorm versus
another dorm and we were like
having a snowball fight in the middle of
this like residential area in bristol
right so it wasn't like in the middle of
a field or something it was literally
like on the roads and the pavements uh
and
i remember we were just throwing
snowballs and
one [ __ ] right you you know you have
like the snowballs and some you you
the common courtesy is you make the
powder snowballs yes of course of course
right of course one [ __ ] decided to
make an ice ball
you know what i mean the ones where it's
like melted ice and you [ __ ] pack it
in
and it's on the side of the road yeah on
the side of the road where you just like
this didn't put a stone in it people
used to do that in
my school seriously i feel like ice
balls are like
even worse because you get you get the
you get the hardness of the ice and the
coldness as well which is like
numbing as well it's basically just
getting a cold rock
yeah yeah yeah so i was i was standing
right by the side of the road
and i see the snowball coming and i'm
just like it's a snowball whatever
hits my [ __ ] balls and then i realize
number one
that is perfect aim because it literally
hit my balls
number two that is not a snowball i just
felt
that is a solid ice ball that just came
full
force right onto my [ __ ] balls i i
have a really similar story but he said
total opposite it was at the beach right
and uh and
my dad and i were at the beach i think i
was like maybe 11 12 years old
right and my dad and i were kicking like
the the rugby ball around
and like one thing i really liked was
trying to catch like the ball that gets
kicked really high up and then you kind
of get under it yeah
like that right so we were doing that a
couple of times i was practicing that
and one time my dad just kicks it really
[ __ ] high up and i was like all right
i got it
sun's in my eyes but i got it i think i
got this and it
comes down it misses my arm and it just
perfectly
flicks my knob
it just flicks out
and i just collapsed yeah because like i
like if if you if you're not a guy if
you're not a male it's really hard to
describe
the pain you feel when your knob gets
flicked or something or
like like it's not you feel an impact
it's not it's not your dick or balls
that hurts it's like above it
it's just the entire area
and so obviously this happened to me and
i was in
total agony right because your mind just
goes blank
so i i start like walking forwards and i
didn't realize i was walking right into
the middle of a road
right because i was just like i was just
like oh
[ __ ] and then
the last thing i remember is my mate go
go what the [ __ ] and he grabs my bag and
pulls me back right here
and pulls me back and then i just see
this [ __ ] bus just going
right in front of me and uh yeah that
was that was
that was the closest i've come to dying
i think imagine you're dying while
grabbing your balls i think you actually
just missed out on your own isa guy
story
yeah right that was your chance that was
one drop
yeah that was that was literally like an
easter guy origin story
yeah i got a snow i got an ice ball i
want to watch an instagram story that
literally starts out like that where the
protagonist gets
smashed in the balls and then gets
transported to another world jesus
christ that's scary